[Music]
I want to be where the people are
I want to see you wanna see them dancing
walking around on those what do you call
them oh feet
flipping your fins
are quiet for jumping dancing
[Music]
alone
oh
my God
over here
[Applause]
[Music]
you broke the rules you went to the
above World a man was drowning I had to
save him this obsession with humans has
to stop I just want to know more about
them
[Music]
don't
poor child I can help you you can't live
in that world unless you become a human
yourself is that even possible
that's what I live for
[Music]
something about you seems different I
can't quite figure it out she got legs
you idiot
I don't know where I don't know how but
I know something's starting right now
watching you'll see
[Music]
he's a human you're a mermaid that
doesn't make us enemies
[Music]
thank you